We're living in a world right
now where we have more data
than we know what to do
with almost, right? And so,
then we turn that corner
to what are those insights,
what are those specific tools,
what's that specific leverage
that we can get to our
customers. And that's
really, I think,
what we wake up every day and
try to put that thinking cap on
and empathize with
the end golfer.
Try solve problems for them they
might not even know they have.
There's been an explosion
of data. So data
on how different
golf balls fly,
data on how golfers
move around the course,
and then layer on top of
that, intelligent analytics
on what does that data mean?
And so we now need
to figure out how to
take that data, take
those measurements, analyze it,
and and ultimately extract
insights to help people play
better golf, enjoy
the game more.
And that requires
tools and structures
to help us not only process
and and and analyze that
data but then also deliver it
to the end user and and help
the customer understand and
leverage those insights that
we're getting from these
new measurements and new technologies.
It's amazing what smart people
can accomplish with with good
tools. But then being
able to take that
and quickly turn it
into a production-grade
commercially-viable
web app and get that out to public
was that was a big win. And since then,
we've taken that momentum and
repeated it several more times.
I think we're just at the very
beginning of being able to
bring this collection of
tools to the everyday golfer.
So I was introduced to PING
through a colleague who is a a
designer here,
and I got in and
started working part-time in the
manufacturing engineering group, and
I just love the
culture. I love
solving problems.
I'd never envisioned that I
would use my engineering degree
to even get into golf design.
So it's been a very fun journey
because I've been able to
invest time in my game, follow
my passion, get better at golf,
join the PGA of America,
and that's opened up some
doors to play competitive tournament
golf. But when that door opened
to get in here, I loved it.
I loved the culture, I
loved learning about all the
unknowns, all the golf
physics that was there,
and the curiosity.
I was an R and D engineer.
He was a designer.
He always has just been
really consumed with what the customer
needs. How do I help
somebody play the game more?
And I was more on the
research side trying to help answer the
questions that he was
posing. I think that culture
of being so curious about how
things work and then being able
to kind of take ownership
to try to solve a problem,
and then ultimately turn
it into a solution for the
customer, right?
And I love that.
As I started working
here at PING,
I started playing golf more
and more, and that became
more of a passion for me even
outside of my time here on
campus doing the
engineering things.
And it's really
helped me understand
the elements of the game that
are a challenge, the pain
of a player trying to get
better and it's really helped
me understand how to ask
the right research questions and
tackle the right areas to
help make golf equipment better.
A lot of new people got
introduced to golf during the
past few years. And so there's
kind of a younger generation, a
network of golfers that
previously weren't introduced
to the game or out there,
And so we've tried to just really,
both from a product standpoint,
from a custom
fitting standpoint,
try to continue that momentum.
PING was founded by
a frustrated engineer, Karsten Solheim.
He founded the company because
he looked at how equipment was
designed and said, hey,
I could bring my engineering
background and make the game
way easier through
some fundamental, you know,
physics principles.
And it's still kind of in the
DNA of PING in what we do.
Every company develops
little centers of excellence;
groups of one or two folks who
who try to solve a problem the
best way they can or the
the best way they knew how.
And one of those that
had developed at PING,
that I learned about,
was a group in engineering
that we're using the R programming
language to help visualize
and share insights and information
about golf data and
how we do business.
Initially,
we started looking at Shiny
apps to help just visualize and
quickly draw insights from data
that we acquired on our range
here, through player testing,
from our motion cap system.
Shiny apps at PING really are
where the first value from R
came out. That's that's Dr.
Henriksen and and Marty and
their teams who are the clever
folks behind those.
A lot of these physics-based
data-driven models
that we were developing
we were developing them
using Posit R Studio.
Then using like the
Shiny framework,
developing these dashboards for our
engineers to then use these
models and use the data we
get from player testing and motion
capture testing to
design equipment.
And so we went to Doug
and we're like, hey,
we have these models.
We're using this Shiny
framework to develop these
Shiny dashboards and apps
to kind of beta test some
different ideas we have for
for tools that would help both
engineers as well
as the end consumer.
Dr.
Hendriksen and his team had
identified R as something they
wanted to work on and
something they wanted to do,
and they had built a handful
of of Shiny applications.
But they did it without the
support of IT and without the
support of the larger
corporate digital strategy.
Because they had to, they
were solving a problem,
they they were innovating.So
I I was glad to be able
to to come in and say,
that's fantastic, but
that doesn't scale,
let's try some some
other techniques.
And that's where Posit
Connect came in. As not only
providing us the ability to
publish these tools that we're
developing, but also host
APIs, and help us move
toward consumer-facing
applications.
Where we can then
build out a front-end
and then hook that into
these APIs and Posit Connect.
The big proof of value came
the first time that I convinced
them to, instead of creating a
Shiny app, create a Plumber API.
And then can I share that
Plumber API with a team within
PING who can build a web
interface around it and publish
that to the public? And
that that really was the, like,
okay, this is gonna work.
Instead of rebuilding
all of our algorithms
and fundamental modeling,
we're able to use APIs
that drive that front-end that our
customers experience without
having to rebuild our
prototype. We just built our
front-end right on top of it.
Posit Connect gives a
tool set to program real
JSON-based APIs - that's fundamental.
If you can't do that,
you're going to have a really
hard time working with any other system.
How it works is that we
take those models and then we're
able to create in that
logic and develop some APIs,
and and through the
Plumber framework and through Connect,
host those, and then
provide this foundation
for other tools
to be developed.
Shiny and Posit Connect
give us that ability to,
in a careful way, in a
protected way, with user access
controls and a reliable
deployment process,
it gives us that ability to
to have their projects be shared
around the company in a
in a controlled, safe, responsible way.
What started with me kind of
playing with it and and prototyping,
quickly evolved into a number
of engineers wanting to get
their hands dirty, make
their own dashboards,
do their own data analysis,
and exploded really quick.
To me, what Posit Connect did
for us was was really brought
that that likelihood of getting
value from the investment and
and the time and the expertise
in data science. That
shortened that life cycle a lot to
Can we can we get this out?
Can we can we build a
consumer-facing product that
has commercial value quickly
and cost-efficiently and and
try to see if it's worth it?
And I'm happy to say that
the solution we've got in place
right now lets us experiment
really, really fast.
It's a lot of fun to be
able to kinda help build this ecosystem
around data.
Not only data when you're
hitting balls on a driving
range or there when you're in
clubs or hitting in a simulator
bay. But more importantly,
what is your data on the
golf course while you're playing golf?
And how can you tie those
things together and make better
product decisions,
custom-fitting decisions?
Where should you be
practicing your game?
Where you're gonna get the most
leverage from your practice in your training?
And it's still early for us
to make those tools available to a
lot of golfers at scale.
Looking at at
Posit and specifically Posit
Connect was not a short-term
solution. I I saw it
as a strategic component of a
long-term vision for for
digital technology at PING.
If it worked out, which I'm
I'm really glad to say it did.
I don't see that runway ending.
That that's a foundational component
to how we continue innovating.